so this is a sample of my favorite
element this is phosphorus phosphorus is
a very very reactive element especially
this type of phosphorus which is white
phosphorus phosphorus itself elemental
phosphorus exists is a number of
different
allotropes so a bit like carbon with
Dimond and graphite and here we have one
of those allotropes it's white
phosphorus it exists as discrete
molecules of four phosphorus atoms
connected like a pyramid and those four
phosphorus atoms are really strained and
really reactive and they want to really
react with oxygen as quick as they can
this is the salt that is used in
phosphorus bombs it burns very easily
and gives a very intense way white light
out of it there you can put it out quite
easily by putting water on it provided
that it hasn't got too hot and the water
will just evaporate very reactive form
the other allotropes black and red
phosphorus and not as as reactive and a
much much easier for us to handle
then there's red phosphorus which is
very much less reactive which is what is
used in matches it's used to make the
heads of so called non-safety matches
which the ones that you can strike on
any sort of material on bricks and so on
and they tend to be this rather red
color yeah so the phosphorus it's you'll
notice that it's stored under water and
it's stored under water to keep the
oxygen in the atmosphere away because it
reacts very vigorously and can burn
hence the signs it's very very flammable
it's so flammable in fact that it burns
just with the heat of the skin so you
can see a number of scars across my
hands these are all from playing with
phosphorus and doing reactions and
experiments with phosphorus phosphorus
is very important point inside your body
some of you may have read Aldous
Huxley's book called brave new world
which when people died they were sent to
the phosphorus reclamation plant and
each average-sized person contains
somewhat over a pound of phosphorus
inside their bodies and nowadays people
can use magnetic resonance imaging
to look and see how the phosphorus is
used inside the body so I've taken a
small sample of my white phosphorus and
I've dissolved it in an organic solvent
which is carbon disulfide because the p4
is molecular and it dissolves really
quite nicely this molecular solvent so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to go outside and we're going to
put this on a piece of filter paper and
then let the carbon disulphide evaporate
so we can see the reaction of the
phosphorus with the oxygen and the paper
and the average person produces inside
their body about 70 kilos a day of a
molecule called ATP adenosine
triphosphate which is the energy
producing molecule inside the body
now you don't keep 70 kilos inside you
or you would explode but you're using it
up all the time but in the course of the
day you synthesize nearly 70 kilos of
this molecule so as the the carbon
disulphide evaporates from the paper
well there's a couple of drips and you
can see that the phosphorus is oxidized
in the air and it's taken some of the
paper with it to generate a nice P for
phosphorus